I'm the president of SFI and welcome to
this new Lam lecture and I'll get into
that in a little more detail but let me
just thank a few folks as always
Thornburg Investment Management for
underwriting the series the lens ik of
course for hosting it and now enterprise
holding foundation I feel like a NPR
news caster but these alarm lectures are
our flagship annual lectures and they
commemorate the life of a prominent
citizen of this town stanislav alam who
lived from 1909 to 1984 it was a polish
american mathematician and nuclear
physicist and he worked on the Manhattan
Project and made all sorts of
interesting discoveries in the area of
stochastic processes and worked in pure
and applied mathematics and was also a
person of wide cultural interest and
these lectures celebrate I think the
spirit of Stanley lambs life with
researchers who aspire to the full range
of creative possibilities and so we want
them to be big thinkers and broad
thinkers and I know somewhere over there
Claire and Steve Wynn are here and
Claire is Stan ulam daughter so it's
always nice to have them in the house oh
thank you very much for coming
and I would just want to say you know
that I you know knowing Clarence Steve
well I mean they are supporters of what
we stand for at SFI which is empiricism
science and ideas as an antidote to
superstition ideology and ignorant and
so yeah and especially important now
you're right and so before introducing
Chris and the topics of these very
important talks that are very timely I
think now I want to give you a quote
from something that Stan ulam wrote on
the topic of the responsibility of the
scientific researcher and this is what
he wrote he said even the simplest
calculation in the purest mathematics
can have terrible consequences without
the invention of the infinitesimal
calculus most of our technology would
have been impossible should we say
therefore that the calculus is bad this
is the moral dilemma of those of us
working in areas that can be applied and
are applied to all sorts of different
ends and computing is one of them of
course Chris who will speak tonight is
an SFI professor his undergraduate
degree was in physics and mathematics
from Northwestern his PhD in dynamical
systems from Cornell he was a postdoc at
the Santa Fe Institute and a professor
at UNM but in case you think we're all
sort of ivory tower eggheads at the
Santa Fe Institute which we are the he
was also city councilors District two
and many people in this town yes
so many years actually and many people
in this house it Chris Moore but isn't
he a politician no no he's a theorist
he's very well decorated he's a fellow
of the American Association of
advancement of science a fellow of the
American Mathematical Society fellow of
the American Physical Society and he
would a wonderful book with another
faculty member SFI a Stephon Merton is
called the nature of computation as
published by oup and it's a huge you
know massive tome but is beautifully
written and actually quite funny which
is surprising for a book of that nature
you know SFI I sometimes feel us we have
too many credentials and too many
publications but there are qualities of
researchers that aren't as evident to
the outside world because what is
typically consumed is the science I just
want to point out that when I bump into
Chris she's often at SFI we don't talk
about science we talk about the novels
of Patrick O'Brien the stories of
Stanislav LEM and Jorge Louie bore his
and the relative merits of Blade Runner
versus Blade Runner 2049 that's what we
talk about and and I want to not be
funny about it I think these are
actually in many ways the sources of our
inspiration and they're not revealed in
the sort of final ultra-filtered sake of
our published work and the saying is
Sark a drip pressed in an ice igloo
that's the purest form and I think it's
good to see things in the raw Chris
lives at the intersection of mathematics
statistical physics and theoretical
computer science and the important point
is he doesn't just stitch or suture
together those areas it's we're not in
the business of building Frankenstein's
monsters at the Santa Fe Institute this
goes under the euphemism sometimes of
interdisciplinary science which is
absolutely of no interest to us we're
interested in foundational similarities
fundamental patterns that recur in
nature across a variety of different
domains and seeking to formalize them
with mathematics and computation and in
that endeavor
is really one of the best so that would
include his work on dynamics on networks
issues of limits to inference when you
have incomplete data quantum computing
and quantum algorithms the computational
complexity of physical systems and even
the application of geometric games to
questions of mathematical proof and
computation time
so tonight Chris's title is easy hard
and impossible problems the limits of
computation and it's not hard to think
about an easier way of limiting human
potential than imagining that computers
are unlimited so Chris thank you very
much for being here tonight so I thought
a lot about what I wanted to say to this
general audience unfortunately I don't
have the symphony behind me tonight as a
backup band some of you were probably
here for that when I look around at the
world it seems like in many places we're
in danger of going backwards that were
giving up on a lot of the progress that
we that we've made over the past century
or so and petty prejudices that I
thought were dying the quiet death they
deserve have come roaring back into life
these prejudices divide us they make it
impossible for us to learn from each
other to empathize with each other or
certainly to solve our problems together
and I honestly believe that science
along with music art literature all the
ways that we express the human spirit
the science is one of the most powerful
antidotes to this slide backwards into
tribalism and by science I don't just
mean the the mass of scientific
knowledge that we've been able to build
up so far although as a as a species we
should all be very proud of that I also
mean the culture of science the practice
of science scientists although we're
humans like anyone else are trained to
do some really good things that most
people
do like admit that we might be wrong
admit that we have more to learn you
know we don't always leave up live up to
these ideals but these are our ideals
and simply by being here tonight you've
shown that your members of this part of
humanity that you you're here because
you want to know more you think that
learning more is a good thing to do and
maybe you even think that the more we
learn the better our chances are of
creating a beautiful society in a
beautiful world so thank you very much
for being here tonight so I'm gonna
introduce you to a branch of science or
really mathematics that you you may have
heard of it's called computer science
but it is not the study of computers
it's the study of computation it's the
study of any situation any system in
which information is being transformed
and in which problems are being solved
so it's really the the art and the
science of problem solving and computers
are not the only things that compute our
brains compute our cells and our bodies
compute and communicate with each other
some people even say that cities and
organizations and markets compute so any
entity which is trying to find a good
solution to a problem that's what the
study of my kind of computer science is
so as we're as we're gonna see tonight
there are some problems that are pretty
easy where you can quickly zoom in on a
solution there's some miraculous
shortcut that lets you immediately see
whether a solution exists there are
others that are fiendishly hard that
require you to search through a huge
haystack a huge space of possible
solutions and that might take you
astronomical time and there are still
other problems that are impossible that
no computer program can solve that in
order to keep solving them you need in
some sense to be endlessly creative so
this is going to take us from some
classic puzzles all the way up through
the paradoxes that lie at the heart of
modern mathematics now tonight's a bit
abstract if you want to hear more about
the impact of computational
decision-making on human be
you should come back tomorrow when we'll
be talking about the rise of algorithms
and they're used in the judicial system
and if you had a friend who couldn't
make it tonight you should tell them to
come back tomorrow because tonight is
not a prerequisite for tomorrow all
right
let's dive in this is a puzzle if you're
the kind of person who likes puzzles you
may have seen it before
this is a map of part of königsberg now
called Kaliningrad and there are there's
a river the river play go and there are
two islands in the river and a total of
seven bridges that connect the islands
to each other and to the two river banks
so the question here is whether it's
possible on a Sunday afternoon strolling
around Koenigsberg to cross each bridge
exactly once we need to cover each one
but not retrace our steps so let's see
if we can do this you know why not we
could go up there starting on that
central island then down over here then
over there then up there up now we're
stuck okay well let's see you let's go
back to the last place where we had a
choice we could go down over here and
then up there and then over there now
we're stuck again with no way to get up
to the upper right there okay I am
carrying out an algorithm as I do this
what is an algorithm named after
al-khwarizmi an algorithm is simply a
method for solving a problem of a
certain kind it could be something that
a human being does it could be something
that a computer program does now the
algorithm I'm carrying out here is try
everything try all possibilities and
well okay that is an algorithm but it
might be a relatively time-consuming one
especially if we were dealing with the
bridges of Venice instead of königsberg
so if you ask me the same puzzle about
Venice and I just said oh I don't know
try every possible path and see if any
of them work you might not be happy with
me a friend of mine at Pittsburgh says
actually Pittsburgh has more bridges
than Venice so in fact for this
particular puzzle there is a much faster
algorithm which avoids doing all this
work of searching through all these
possibilities and it
is brought to us by a mathematician
named Leonardo Euler who invented a
whole new branch of mathematics largely
to deal with this problem
so his branch of mathematics is called
graph theory and we still use it today
to study social networks biological
networks food webs transfer
transportation networks and so on so
what he's done is he's taken the four
locations that we had there the two
islands the two riverbanks and just made
the map a little more abstract so each
one is now a single node in this little
network and each bridge is an edge
between those two nodes so now the game
is can we draw this covering each bridge
exactly once it's a lot like the old
puzzle of can you draw this picture
without lifting your pencil from the
page and without retracing any of your
steps okay well this is a new
representation but hasn't really changed
our ability to solve the problem now
oiler comes in with a wonderful
observation he says according to the
rules of the game since you can only go
across each bridge once at every node
the bridges must come in pairs if you
entered it on a long one you have to
leave on another so they come in pairs
enter leave and her leave enter leave
except maybe the first and last nodes
where we begin and end our path all
right now armed with that insight all we
have to do is notice that all four of
these nodes all four of these locations
have an odd number of bridges three
three three and five so there is no path
possible we're done well notice what
oiler has done for us here he's given us
a much faster algorithm which released
us completely from the obligation of
searching through all these
possibilities and this algorithm of just
checking the oddness or evenness of the
number of bridges at each node would
work perfectly well for the bridges of
venice it would be pretty quick to check
them all so he's given us a very
efficient way to solve this puzzle and
by the way these were called Euler Ian
paths in his honor
so Euler Ian pasture one's the cross
each bridge was
good now let me show you another puzzle
which at first sounds almost the same
these are called Hamiltonian paths named
after a certain Hamilton who made a lot
of contributions to mathematics and
physics here the game is just a little
bit different in instead of crossing
each edge once we have to visit each
node once so if you've heard of the
Traveling Salesman problem there you
have like a map of cities and you want
to visit each one exactly once so in
this particular example of this puzzle I
have taken one of my favorite things the
dodecahedron that's one of the Platonic
solids and I've squashed it to make the
network on the right and I want you to
ponder for a moment if you think it's
possible to start somewhere there and
tour around on the edges and visit each
place exactly once maybe even come back
to where you started not obvious how to
figure this out well there are lots of
solutions here's one of them ok so these
are called Hamiltonian paths and one of
the reasons why we named them after
Hamilton is that he unsuccessfully
marketed a game where the first player
chooses the first five steps of the path
and the second player has to try to
complete it now the funny thing is that
unlike the oil Arian path problem where
we had this brilliant shortcut which
immediately told us whether or not a
path exists here essentially the only
way we know how to solve this problem is
by search by searching through all the
possibilities and how might we organize
this well it might look like this tree
where you take that first step and then
there are two choices of what to do next
each of those leads to two choices each
of those leads to two choices and so on
and you would follow down this tree
systematically examining every possible
path until you might reach a leaf of the
tree where maybe you've succeeded in
solving the whole puzzle or you've
gotten stuck somewhere and in that case
you would backtrack and try another
branch of the tree go back to the last
place where you had a choice well again
this is a perfectly fine algorithm but
there's a problem
so suppose that we're looking at an
apostle of this con
but instead of just 20 nodes we had n
nodes where n is a hundred or a thousand
or something
well if roughly speaking the number of
choices we have at each node is two the
total number of choices we have to
explore is two times two times two n
times the nth power of two two raised to
the n now this is an exponential
function I know that we like to say in
popular culture something is growing
exponentially just cuz it's growing
really fast but for people like me this
is a precise meaning it means that this
function is doubling every time n
increases by one well what's so bad
about that well let me take you back to
middle school or high school and remind
you about polynomials so a polynomial is
a function like n squared that's n times
n and cubed is n times n times n and if
we have a method of solving a problem
where if the problem is of size n like
it has n cities on the map if we can do
it in n squared or n cube time we're
reasonably happy because even if N is a
thousand well a thousand squared is only
a million a thousand cubed is only a
billion and your computer does a billion
things every seconds that's no big deal
on the other hand two times itself a
thousand times 2 raised to the
thousandth power is this number which is
much bigger than the number of stars in
the sky so it's the only method
available to us costs this much takes
this much work we're not going to solve
our problem anytime soon let me give one
more illustration of this polynomial
versus exponential thing so the simplest
polynomial of n is n it grows like n ok
we got that and squared grows like the
area of a square which is n by N and
cubed grows like the volume of a cubical
box and by N by n but here's another
illustration of our exponential legend
has it that the emperor of India was so
grateful to the inventor of chess for
creating this fantastic new board game
that he said I'll give you anything you
want to reward you for this
what do you need and the inventor said
well people in my village are kind of
hungry could you please put one grain of
rice on the first square of a chessboard
and then two on the next square and then
four and then eight and then sixteen
doubling every doubling at every square
and the upper set of course make it so
and then someone the Grand Vizier or the
extraor the rice steward or someone had
to say my liege after only 20 squares we
have more than a million grains of rice
after only 30 squares we have more than
a billion and after all 64 we have about
18 and a half quadrillion I had to count
the commas there to get that right and
that's more than all the rice that has
ever been or will ever be so if that's
the cost of solving a problem it's going
to be a very hard problem so I'm trying
to get across this idea to you that when
we have a polynomial time algorithm we
have some shortcut like Euler's if we
don't have a shortcut we just have to
search every possibility we might be
dealing with this kind of exponential
cost and that will be much more
challenging for us so to wrap this
little section up the boil Aryan paths
crossing each edge exactly once
have a very nice shortcut just check
that each node is an even number of
bridges you don't need to search on the
other hand the Hamiltonian paths is
there sorry wrong wrong Hamilton the the
Hamiltonian paths where we have to visit
each edy
each node exactly once not only do we
not have such a shortcut but as I will
show you we have very good reasons for
believing there is no such shortcut okay
it's not just a matter that somebody
clever like Euler hasn't come along and
shown us how to do it there is no way to
avoid searching through a vast number of
possibilities and this is the kind of
distinction between easy problems and
hard problems that people like me want
to understand so what is it about these
two problems that make one so much
harder than the other well let me
discuss another method for zooming in on
solutions
it's a terrible method for almost every
problem that you or I will ever meet
it's called a greedy algorithm and it
lives in the moment what it does at
every instant is make the move that
seems in the short-term will make the
most progress it never thinks ahead it
never plans ahead it's the grasshopper
anyway so this type of algorithm goes
back to a gentleman named Otto kore
Otakon Baraka
I hope I'm getting that right who in the
1920s was designing an early electric
power network for towns in his native
Bohemia now he wanted to connect all
these towns with electric wires and if
you just want to make sure that there's
one path from each town to each other
town you don't need a loop because that
would give you two ways to get there
right so all you really need is a tree
that stretches out and connects all the
towns to all the other towns actually
this is a terrible idea for a power grid
because if one of these edges gets cut
down by falling tree tree then it would
break into two pieces so it is no
redundancy or resilience or any of that
but okay so he wanted to find the tree
this is called a spanning tree in graph
theory the branch of mathematics that
euler invented with the smallest total
length of all the power lines right to
minimize the cost or if you prefer maybe
some of them might go over some
mountaintop and that would cost more so
you can think of it as the smallest
total cost if you wish but let's talk
about length so he came up with this
algorithm which seems incredibly naive
all you do at each step is connect the
pair of cities that has the shortest
link between them that won't complete a
loop because we don't need loops that's
the whole algorithm so see we'll start
with that pair in the middle and then
maybe that pair over there and over
there now we kind of have some ties and
anyway so this algorithm proceeds now we
have a
Manningtree we have a network which does
connect all the cities but is this the
best possible I mean why should we
believe that this very naive algorithm
out of all the spanning trees which
might have connected them managed to
find the one with the smallest total
length well for this particular problem
amazingly this works I can kind of short
a search I can kind of sort of show you
the proof actually so suppose that the
algorithm wanted to add that link up
there which I call E for edge but for
purposes of argument let's suppose that
the one it should have added was a
different longer one down there
EEP rhyme well add both now you have a
tree with a loop but now you could cut a
prime and you would still be held
together by E but remember our
assumption was that e was shorter so
that was good you now have a spanning
tree with a smaller total length and the
algorithm was right all along
got it that was a proof by contradiction
so for you st. John's people so for this
particular problem this algorithm works
which is surprising I mean when you're
playing chess I'm not very good at chess
but sometimes you have to
I don't know sacrifice your rook so that
you can save your queen later or
something or or win the game three moves
later or something so in almost every
situation certainly all the problems
that we deal with in society and or the
environment you need to think ahead and
you sometimes need to make sacrifices
you sometimes need to make things a
little bit better or a little bit worse
in order to make them better later on
now there are lots of other problems in
computer science where greedy algorithms
totally fail so for instance here's the
Traveling Salesman problem so there used
to be these people called traveling
salesman's they had they had suitcases
had families they went from town to town
selling things this was a long time ago
so suppose we start out here in the
lower-left now a greedy algorithm would
go to the nearest city that you haven't
been to yet that would be the kind of
short-term thing to do but if you do
that you follow this path and then say
oh no we skipped Topeka we have to go
all the way back here and that's going
to cost us about twice as much as what
we should have done which was be less
greedy and go out of our way at first
make a little sacrifice cover that city
and then handle the rest of the chain so
what have we learned from this we've
learned that these two problems which
are not so different on the surface
connecting things with a tree or
connecting them with a path for one of
them greed is good
and for the other it often leads us down
the primrose path and takes us in the
wrong direction what makes the
difference well there is a concept which
shows up in a lot of Sciences called the
landscape so imagine the landscape as
this vast space of all possible
solutions to a problem and the height of
wherever you are is the quality of that
solution well some landscapes look like
this we call them Mount Fuji landscapes
seriously there's one great solution
which dominates the landscape and
there's a simple reliable way to find it
start anywhere on the mountainside and
walk up it doesn't really matter how
good you are walking up or which way you
walk up if there are several choices
just keep walking up keep making little
improvements and the nice thing about
this is it works even in the fog because
after all you don't have a map of all
the solutions if you did that would make
things too easy so even if you don't
know what your options are even if you
have no idea what the world of possible
solutions looks like if you just keep
making little improvements you're
guaranteed to reach the summit
you know shortly after I first moved to
Santa Fe I was hiking with some people
and I said I'm tired I'm gonna I'm going
back home and I forgot that fruit I
forgot that for going
now this doesn't work there are lots of
ways to go down and some of them leave
you out onto some County Road where then
some nice person picks you up with a
truck before you die of thirst anyway
now so for this type of problem if this
is how the landscape is structured you
can start nearly anywhere and make
whatever greedy improvements you can
make and you'll find the summit you'll
find the best solution but of course
most problems look more like this we
have lots and lots of options we have
lots and lots of solutions and maybe the
best one is a little bit better than the
one over here but if you start in a
random place and again without the
benefit of a map and you just start
walking up from wherever you started you
almost certainly won't find that highest
mountain peak you'll get stuck on some
smaller peak you'll get stuck in what we
call a local optimum a place where if
you make any small change any small
motion away from where you are you'll
make things worse because you're
stepping down off that peak okay
so small changes are not going to
improve the solution there is some huge
change that would cause you to jump all
the way over to the summit first or
perhaps first go through a valley where
things would get much worse before they
got better the problem is that it's
worse than this picture suggests because
it's not just a two or three dimensional
landscape it's some kind of high-end
dimensional landscape and again we don't
have a map so you don't know how to get
to the summit and this forces you to
explore you have to do a lot of
exploration and somehow this is what
makes a lot of the problems we need to
deal with hard now I should mention that
this happens even in other sciences for
instance in ecology we talk about the
fitness landscape where species are
trying to evolve by mutating a bit and
they want to maximize their chances of
survival and the chances of survival of
their children in physics things like to
settle to low energy states so we
flipped the landscape over and now
valleys are good and Peaks are bad
anyway so
so you know rocks rocks rolled downhill
in physics so if you next time you're
looking at a window
well that window glass is made of pretty
much silicon and oxygen it's basically
sand which has been melted and then
cooled back down it turns out that the
state it really wants to be in is that
one on the right a perfect crystal that
would be the lowest energy state that's
kind of the solution to the problem that
the atoms are trying to solve but they
never find it instead they get stuck in
a much more jumbled state in fact if you
look at window glass on an atomic level
it looks looks more like a liquid than
like a crystal so why did it get stuck
well maybe some of the atoms on the left
we're trying to line up with each other
they were trying to solve their part of
the problem some of the ones on the
right were trying to solve their part of
the problem but these two solutions that
they found to their parts of the problem
aren't compatible they don't knit
together to a solution of the entire
problem maybe this sounds familiar to
you so in order to get to that perfect
crystal we would have to pay a huge cost
a big rearrangement of one of these
parts greatly increasing the energy
before it could fall into place with the
other part and so this is a problem
where literally the atoms are trying to
solve that they're having trouble
computing where they ought to be and
they get stuck for a very long time
all right good so what's next well let's
go back to our Hamiltonian path problem
finding a way to tour this network and
visit each node once may be hard but if
I show you the solution all you have to
do it takes a glance to say oh yeah it
goes around and yeah business everywhere
it works so for this problem you can
check solutions they might be hard to
find but they're easy to check that's
not nothing right because for a lot of
problems it's even hard to tell when you
have the right solution so you know if
you if God gives you a solution in a
dream or you trip over one on the
sidewalk you can at least
make sure that it works so this brings
us to these things that we call
complexity classes P and NP P stands for
polynomial those the ones that we know
how to solve pretty quickly without a
lot of search NP are the ones where we
can check solutions quickly it doesn't
mean you can find them but you can check
them we like to use this metaphor of a
needle in a haystack you know you could
have a huge haystack of possible
solutions to a problem and it might be
very hard for you to find the needle in
it or to tell if there is a needle in it
and yet if you pick up a particular
thing you can prick your finger with it
and check to see if it works now this
gives us a kind of map of possible
problems so P down here contains a
Larian path the spanning tree problem we
saw that burr if Co came up with
Hamiltonian path lives up there and in
fact we think it's kind of near the top
of NP it's in a class we call
np-complete these are the hardest
problems up there so these the ones that
we think that is really hard to find the
solution and I'm going to explain to you
why so in order to explain to you why we
believe so strongly except for a handful
of heretics why we believe so strongly
that these problems are really hard I
need to explain to you a bit more about
the innards of a computer so of course
they're ubiquitous but what are they
doing inside them in their guts so you
know we know intuitively they're dealing
with numbers symbols all sorts of things
but at the root level what they're
dealing with are things called bits bits
aren't even numbers they can only take
two different values 0 or 1 or on or off
true or false that's all they can do so
everything is made in bits in a computer
and now just as there's arithmetic we
can do on numbers we can add two numbers
and get a third we can multiply them and
get a third there are things we can do
to bits they're called and or and not so
for instance I could take two bits
combine them and get a result which
is true it's on only if both of these
bits were on this one and that one that
was certainly come in handy sometime
accelerate the car if the drivers foot
is on the pedal and there's no one in
the crosswalk then we can also do the or
where the result is true if either one
or possibly both of the inputs are true
and then finally there's naught which
flips the switch and changes on to off
and vice versa so if you were to look at
a circuit diagram in a computer you
might see something like this each of
these is made of a couple of transistors
and these are little and and or gates
which are taking bits and combining them
and spitting out the result and somehow
doing some job for us computing
something so here's what the and gates
look like they're the round ones and
again if both of the things going into
it or either one are zero then it puts
out a zero but if they're both one it
puts out a one and an or gate if either
if they're both zeros it puts out a zero
but if either one or both is a one it
puts out a 1 so these are the basic
elements inside every computer and when
we compute something whether it's you
know just watching a YouTube counters
computing something whenever we do
whenever we do anything on a computer
it's breaking it down into these tiny
pieces these tiny steps now I'm going to
tell you about something completely
different
hold what I just said in your mind okay
because this only seems different so
here I have a map of South America and
I've colored it as is traditional to
avoid confusion whenever two colors
sorry whenever two countries meet at a
border I've used different colors there
so we can see the border clearly now
there's an old result in mathematics
that four colors are always enough here
I have red blue yellow and orange so
this actually took a really long time to
prove it was suggested in the mid-1800s
and it wasn't proved until a hundred and
twenty five years later in the 1970s
that four colors are in
it's called the four colormap theorem
and in fact it's kind of controversial
because the best proof we have still
involves a lot of computer assistants to
check a bunch of cases
so not everyone regards it as a good
proof
so there's therein lies a tale anyway
but for some maps three colors are
enough is that true for this map could I
change the colors and you know reshuffle
things and maybe get rid of the orange
and just have three colors that's a
puzzle I'm gonna try to show you why
this puzzle can be very hard so but
first I'm gonna transform it into
another kind of question on networks
like Euler did I'm gonna have a node
corresponding to each country and then
whenever two countries are sure a border
I'll draw a link between them so now the
question is can I color the nodes of
this network so that no two nodes of the
same color if they have a direct link
okay well here's another puzzle like
that I change the pellet blue purple and
yellow I've colored some things in
already let's start with that one on the
bottom I think I'll color that purple
well I only have three colors to work
with so the one to the left of the one I
just colored see it's in between a blue
and a purple well it better be yellow
then because it can't be the same as
either of those well the one above those
two the blue and the yellow had better
be purple that one had better be blue
things are going well I think I'll color
the one on the left of the middle there
yellow oh now I'm stuck because I've
taken all three colors from the one to
the right
okay I'm not dead yet I'll move the
other one over there then this one can
be blue that one has to be yellow that
has to be purple now I'm stuck again
what am I doing here I'm crawling around
well hopefully walking around on that
bumpy landscape so I've I've gotten
stuck at a little at a little mountain
peak
I haven't solved the entire problem I've
solved most of it but now I'm stuck and
indeed no small change I can make is
gonna make things any better I have to
go all the way back oh yes that's what I
was just saying
I have to go all the way back to when I
colored that one on the middle of the
bottom purple and recolor it blue and
now everything works okay why is he
telling us this because I've designed
this puzzle so that it is sneaking in
some computation this thing is actually
an and gate where the blue things are
zero or false and the purple things are
one or true and there's the and gate and
it has those two inputs and that output
and as you recall if a NAND gate has a 1
and a 0 going into it because those are
not both true it must output a 0 so that
one must be blue so what am I saying I'm
saying that I can disguise computation
as coloring puzzles I can sneak
computation into this puzzle about
coloring with 3 colors and that should
tell you that it's not so easy to tell
whether I can color things with 3 colors
because I could be doing sneakily some
complicated computation in disguise and
indeed once I have one of these I can
wire them together and make a big
network which is actually well it could
be searching for a traveling salesman
tour of less than 10,000 miles up the
eastern seaboard
it could be solving our original
Hamiltonian path problem it could be
doing all sorts of other things in
disguise so that suggests that this is
not so simple a kind of puzzle well
having shown you how to compute with
colors let's change slightly to
computing with cats I'm a cat person
here is a puzzle of wooden pieces that
are carved to look like cats more
abstractly if you're not a cat person
these are pentominoes you've heard of
dominoes dominoes are two squares stuck
together pentominoes from the Greek
Penta for five are four squares stuck
together you can make a bunch of
different shapes out of those and if
you're like me then you enjoy trying to
fit these into some some shape and
you're proud if you make it work now
how do these puzzles work well you often
solve almost all of them and then you
get stuck and there's a shape for the P
shaped Kitty but the one you have left
is the S shaped Kitty and you have to
rearrange everything and toss it all
back out into the coffee table to get it
to work
thumpy landscape okay
stuck on those little mountain peaks now
why are puzzles like this tricky because
even with these simpler shapes which I
was able to find after some effort
pictures of cats to fit in them even
with these simpler shapes we can do
computation again we're gonna sneak it
in we're going to design shapes where
there's a kind of wire which can be
filled in with the elbow shaped Kitty
either this way or that way and that
will mean true and false and then we
come up with some junctions which act
like and and or gates so that solving
this puzzle corresponds to carrying out
some computation so again that's why we
think this type of puzzle can be hard
because I focused so much on Hamilton
you can do this even with Hamiltonian
paths remember the rule is we have to
visit each node once I put arrows on the
edges that you have to follow I don't
want you to go backward you know forgive
me so the question is can we get all the
way from the top to all the way at the
bottom well there are these three things
that look kind of like rope bridges but
because you can only visit each node
once once you start across them you have
to keep going in the same direction well
that will be my true and false why not
and then I'll add that little thing on
the side so that after you choose values
for these three bits let's call them x
y&z and after we say that maybe going
from left to right is true and right to
left is false then well you have to
visit that node on the side that's one
of the rules of the game but I've
arranged the arrows from these bridges
so that you can only visit it if X is
false or if Y is true or if Z is true
and once I can build that kind of thing
I can build and and or gates and I can
build a whole computer out of this
so computing in disguise if any of these
problems were easy if any of these
problems had a shortcut like Euler's
shortcut then well for one thing
thousands of other problems would also
suddenly be easy because I can disguise
thousands of other problems like these
these problems would also all be easy as
each other because they can also be each
other in disguise why not now would this
be a good thing if I could solve all
these tricky puzzles very quickly
without having to search without having
to get stuck without having to tear my
hair out at the coffee table well it
would mean something profound
it would mean remember that NP was this
class of problems where solutions are
easy to check ok if any of these
problems were easy it would mean that
anything which is easy to check is also
easy to find that sounds odd again think
of the needle in the haystack just
because I can prick my finger with a
needle and check that it actually draws
blood doesn't mean that I can magically
find it in a huge haystack let's say I
don't have a magnet so it sounds strange
to think that anything which is easy to
check is easy to find we don't believe
that's true
now some people would find it convenient
the traveling salespeople would have
better routes it would be easy to pack
your luggage in your car you wouldn't
have that situation where you fit in
almost all the suitcases and then
there's the wrong space and you have to
throw everything back out on the
driveway you wouldn't have to deal with
that bumpy landscape it also code
breaking would be really easy because
after all if I intercept a message that
you sent to your friend and ice managed
to figure out the secret key I can I
usually know when I've got it right
right it says meet me under the banyan
tree at 3:30 a.m. or something like that
I got it right it's not just gibberish
well if P and NP were the same then all
codes would be easy to break almost all
because anything which is easy to check
is easy to find
so we don't believe this we think this
is crazy talk one of the biggest reasons
we think this is crazy talk is that
science would be too easy this this I
could not bear so here is Johannes
Kepler and he looks through his
telescope and he checks the numbers
really carefully and he has a brilliant
insight he says they're going around in
ellipses not in circles brilliant
thought but it's pretty easy to check
afterward just you know run the numbers
like oh yeah you're right they're
ellipses here's Lynn Margulis who had a
brilliant thought in biology that a lot
of the little organelles the little
machines running around in our cells
we're at one time independent organisms
which were then in a symbiosis with us
and then got swallowed up brilliant
thought once you have that thought then
you look around and there's a lot of
evidence for it I refuse to believe that
everything we can check post facto like
this that we can find evidence backing
it up afterward is easy to come up with
in the first place then we wouldn't need
people like Lynn Margulis and Johannes
Kepler to have great ideas we wouldn't
need cleverness and insight so that's
what I think about that now we've talked
about easy problems and hard problems
what time is it good let's talk about
impossible problems so we've talked
about problems that there's a quick
shortcut we've talked about problems
where there is an enormous amount of
searching to do are there problems that
can't be solved by a computer no matter
how much time you give it well let's
delve a little bit into the history of
computers so here's Charles Babbage who
by the way hated street musicians and he
proposed a mechanical computer which was
never quite built I've seen pieces of it
in the British Museum and it was there
was a version of it built out of mekin
oh that's that kind of advanced Lego
erector set type type stuff anyway it
didn't get built in his lifetime but Ada
Lovelace studied it and studied his
designs and in addition to being the
first person who
a complicated computer program for it
ADA also had an insight which is kind of
part of the air we breathe now which is
that if you have a computer that can
represent numbers then it could also
represent lots of other things for
instance music so she talked about oh if
you could build this maybe you could
find some ways to generate new musical
compositions so the world we live in now
where data works equally well to
represent pictures videos audio music
text stories and numbers that's really
that was a decision of where this was
going and I think that may be why in a
steampunk universe she and Babbage have
formed a crime-fighting team you can buy
that online alright sorry I just want
that to run another moment ok good so
now as the 20th century wore on people
were really trying to understand what
our computers capable of and this was
intimately bound up with studying the
very foundations of mathematics logic
and set theory the things that are kind
of down there in the you know in the
sub-basement of mathematics underneath
the geometry and the algebra trying to
make sure that the logic holds together
and to study this you often need to deal
with paradoxes with things biting their
own tails or maybe mobius strips coming
around and meeting themselves with a
twist so that every time you go around
it you find yourself on the other side
of what you thought you were on because
these paradoxes reveal things to us
about what actually makes sense and
sometimes reveals to us that things we
thought made sense didn't make sense so
here for instance is the classic
empanada is the Cretan saying all
Cretans are liars if he's lying is
telling the truth if he's telling the
truth he's lying actually this isn't the
paradox at all do you know why it could
be that he's a liar but that lots of
other cretins aren't see because then
he's lying they're not all liars then
there's no paradox anyway for some
reason people often
miss that um here's another paradox that
was brought up by Bertrand Russell the
philosopher and one of the founders of
set theory here's the English version
you've probably heard it the barber
shaves those and only those in town who
do not shave themselves does the barber
shave themself well if they do then we
just been told that they don't and if
they don't we've been told that they do
so something's wrong now for Russell
this was not about barbers it was about
sets containing themselves so he was
trying to understand again set theory a
set could be the set of this podium the
numbers one through seven the color blue
and how about itself can it belong to
itself well if you have sets the belong
to themselves then you can get in this
kind of trouble where you ask about the
set that contains all sets that don't
contain themselves got it does if it
doesn't doesn't if it does so these are
not just little games they reveal to us
that we have to be careful as we figure
out what the mathematics is of sets
which were very basic objects and math
anyway so um these paradoxes help reveal
things to us and a whole slew of people
in the 20th century David Hilbert Rosa
Peter Alonzo Church Julia Robinson and
many others were trying to understand
the foundations of mathematics and at
the same time the foundations of
computation Julia Robinson is worth
mentioning because there's a wonderful
science technology and engineering and
mathematics festival named after her and
she also had this lovely quote I won't
read the whole thing but she says I
think of mathematicians as forming a
nation of our own without origin race
creed sex age it's a lovely thought I
think it's it's not a coincidence that
scientists and mathematicians prefer to
build bridges than walls it's just kind
of how we are okay so here's Alan Turing
now you've probably heard of him because
of his heroic work in cracking the
enigma code that the Nazis were using
during World War two
and this played a major role in the war
sad to say he didn't stay with us very
long after that because he was
persecuted by his society for being
homosexual and that drove him to suicide
and much too late many years later the
Prime Minister of England apologized for
this and said look you know this person
played a key role the war might have
gone very differently if it hadn't been
for his code breaking I'm deeply sorry
yeah well yes I am too it's I often
wonder what computer science would be
like now if Turing had lived a whole
lifetime with us because in addition to
code breaking he did many other things
for those of us at the Santa Fe
Institute who study complex systems he's
kind of a hero because for instance he
figured out how the leopard got its
spots
so he mathematically modeled chemicals
getting concentrated and interacting
with each other and flowing from one
space to another and figuring out how
zebras get stripes and I guess this is
actually a Jaguar get these spots so
that was amazing they're still called
Turing patterns in his honor
he also wrote one of the early and very
important papers about artificial
intelligence so he contemplated you know
this is very early in the age of
computers they were not very powerful by
modern standards but he was
contemplating will there ever be an
intelligence coming out of these
computers and he was very far seeing in
this in that he predicted that if we
ever do that it'll be more like raising
a child than like programming a computer
and this is indeed how neural networks
work now we don't program the neural
network we don't say do this and do that
we give it lots of data lots of examples
and then it trains itself or learns what
it should do there is a poignant
paragraph here where he says the child
could not be asked to go out and fill
the coal-scuttle
and one should not send it to school
without the other children making
excessive fun of it which so I assume he
meant that to sting a little bit when he
said it
anyway so a founder of all these
different fields now what we're going to
talk about here is his halting problem
and you can already sense that it has
the seeds of the paradox in it the
question is is there a computer program
which if you ask it about some other
computer program any other computer
program it can accurately predict
whether that other program will run
forever or whether it will someday halt
well this would really come in handy for
instance for a little while Microsoft
had a competitor to the Apple music
player which on December 31st 2008
suddenly stopped working because it got
stuck in an endless loop because it was
confused about the date in the leap year
to be fair this also happens sometimes
with Apple products so if you could
solve this halting problem you could
check to see if your computer is going
to get stuck in an endless loop but more
important you could do some amazing
things and solve unsolved mathematical
questions let me remind you that the
prime numbers are numbers like 2 3 5 7
and more numbers which are not anything
smaller times something they're like
elementary particles they can't be
broken down by multiplication into
smaller pieces well it turns out that a
long time ago someone named Christian
Goldbach with a beautiful signature
wrote a letter to our old friend oiler
saying gee it seems to me that every
number bigger than 4 is the sum the
addition of two odd Prime's okay let's
check 6 is 3 plus 3 12 is 5 plus 7 we
can keep on checking bigger and bigger
numbers and this has been checked up to
4 quintillion but we still don't know
don't you love that I mean this is such
a basic question prime numbers even
numbers adding two things together you
can explain to a third grader that this
is a question to which no one knows the
answer I'm kind of passionate about this
as someone involved in mathematics
education because
in the usual mathematics class well you
get homework or tests and the teacher
knows the right answer and the question
is can you figure it out
here we don't know the right answer and
I really like letting people know that
mathematics has a lot of this and not
even far out even very basic questions
we don't know the answer well if we
could solve the halting problem no sweat
because here is a program don't worry
about it too much you don't need to know
Python or anything like that it starts
out by setting X equal to 6 6 is the
first even number bigger than 4 then it
says try all the numbers y&z between 1
and in that case 6 as soon as you find 2
where this one is prime and that one is
prime and y plus Z equals x6 whatever
good now add 2 to X and go on to the
next even number 8 10 12 and so on
well if Goldbach's conjecture is true
this will run forever it will just
happily keep finding pairs of primes
that add up to things and it will never
stop but if Goldbach's conjecture is
false if there's some number way out
there which is not the sum of two odd
primes it will halt and so I found a
counter example
so if Turing's halting problem were
solvable we wouldn't even need to run
this program we would just ask the
miraculous halting predicting program
about this program and as soon as it
tells us yes it will run forever or no
it will halt we know the answer that
does sound a bit too easy doesn't it at
least to me that would be disappointing
that'd be cheating well in fact there's
no such program you cannot predict
halting here's why and maybe you kind of
get the idea well you could ask it about
itself with a twist
so let's even call it mobius after the
twisty mobius strip so this is a little
program where you give it another
program P
and if P would halt when given itself as
input this one runs forever if he would
run forever
this one halts now ass good about itself
so now it's bid its own tail it runs
forever if it halts and it halts if it
runs forever we can't have it both ways
so this is a contradiction and the only
escape from this paradox is that there's
no such program there's no way to solve
the halting problem so now you know
maybe when you read the leaflet and I
you heard I was going to talk about
things that no computer can do you
thought I yes enjoy strawberries and
cream no computer can do that well I
agree so far at least but this is a math
question that no computer can solve it's
a question about computers that no
computer can solve so it's interesting
to know that there are limits there to
what they can do I want to finish up by
pointing out that there is if anything
oh by the way yes this is the dr. Seuss
version of this I won't read it all I'll
just read the part that says well the
truth is that P cannot possibly be
because if you wrote it and gave it to
me I could use it to set up a logical
bind that would shatter your reason and
scramble your mind it goes on this is
just the first few stanzas okay good now
now that we know that there's no way to
solve the halting problem this turns out
to have in many ways an even more
profound consequence another one of the
great logicians and mathematicians who
is trying to understand this in the 20th
century was kurt gödel so Goodell who
hang out with Einstein for a long time
at Princeton later on in his life proved
something kind of amazing which you may
have never thought about it before
but you know maybe you took Euclidian
geometry or something like that where
you didn't just have to come up with
answers in math you really had to prove
them you really had to come up with a
proof so good ole showed that there are
on
unprovable truths and this is also
connected to Turing's work let me
explain
suppose it were the case that every time
a program was going to run forever
there was a proof that it was going to
run forever you with me if that were
true we could solve the halting problem
by doing two things at once in parallel
run the program and see if it halts if
it halts you knew it halts and look for
proofs longer and longer proofs that it
won't halt if there were always proofs
whenever it doesn't halt that it doesn't
halt then one of these two things would
be guaranteed to happen and we could
solve the halting problem so the fact
that we can't means that sometimes it's
true that the program will never halt
but there's no proof of that
that's kind of interesting because
before good will came along people
thought well of course mathematics is
this branch of science where you prove
things we're gonna prove all the true
things that's what we want to do he's
saying there's some true things you
can't prove to be more precise there's
no one logical system that can prove all
the true things in math each one has
some truths outside of it that it cannot
grasp no matter how powerful it is no
one system can handle at all is this bad
news no this is great news it means that
mathematics will never be over it will
never be complete it's going to be a
living thing mathematics will never be
something like this where there's a
machine where you just turn the crank
and all the true things pop out no it'll
be more like this where we're constantly
looking beyond the systems that we have
we're constantly looking for new forms
of reasoning new ways to prove things
new ways to explore to think and to
learn and if that's true in mathematics
it's surely true in the rest of life
thank you
does anyone have any questions ones that
I can answer or Alize can pretend to
make an effort Chris thank you today the
popular press reports a possible proof
of the Riemann hypothesis
I haven't yet checked beyond the popular
press I'm there all right I'm in the
same boat yes so the question is so
there are several along with Goldbach
conjecture you know there are these
grand unsolved questions that have you
know been like the fixed stars in the
firmament for mathematics some of them
for centuries and one of them is called
the Riemann hypothesis and it's about
the detailed structure of the prime
numbers and if we could solve that than
many other things in mathematics would
fall into place so of very distinguished
mathematicians from Michael attea
announced that he had finally proved it
and he gave a talk today and like my
friend here I don't really know what he
said or whether other mathematicians
were convinced by it there was some
skepticism but you know even if he has a
new approach even if he wasn't able to
complete it that would already be very
interesting he's also 90 years old and
he said explicitly in some of the press
he's tired of hearing that people do
their best work in mathematics by the
age of 30 so he is going to prove that
he can nail this unsolved problem at the
age of 90 so I hope he's done it I don't
honestly know but yes this is this is
hot off the presses he gave the talk
literally today we have a question over
here
does the approaching world of quantum
computing change any of your conclusions
I thought someone might ask that thank
you so remember we had this class P the
pretty easy things NP the things that
really require a lot of search the
majority view although we could be wrong
is that what quantum computers can do is
kind of in between so for instance we
talked about the prime number
there's this basic question called
factoring right if I give you a number
35 breaking it down into its factors
means saying ah that's 5 times 7 and if
you could do that for very large numbers
you could for instance break the public
key cryptosystem on which most of
banking is currently based there
wouldn't be any large mathematical
consequences just the collapse of the
banking system and so we know that if we
could build quantum computers we could
solve that problem quickly which is why
a number of agencies with three-letter
names are trying to figure out new
crypto systems that even quantum
computers will have difficulty breaking
so what we don't in fact believe that
quantum computers could solve all of the
NP or np-complete problems and you know
there's there's a lot of discussion in
the press you know I mean how do you
explain quantum computing to people it's
kind of true that quantum computers get
to try many things at once but that's
not really it it's more like it can it
can be in yes you can try multiple
things at once but some of them you know
build up with each other because they're
in phase like when a bunch of light
particles are all in phase we get a
laser it's very bright some of them
cancel each other out because they're
out of phase like you're noise
cancelling headphones work by producing
sound which is equal and opposite to the
sound that you're hearing so what
quantum computers get to do is carefully
arrange this interference as we call it
between these waves in the hope that the
wrong answers will cancel out and the
right answer pops out so we know we can
do that for factoring interestingly
enough it's not obvious what else this
works for we know that we could simulate
quantum materials much more quickly than
we can on a standard computer and so on
but it's still not obvious what quantum
computers will be able to do there was a
meeting at at the Santa Fe Institute
just last year where you
actually it was a lot of fun for me
because I got to have these people with
these different competing technologies
there are some people at UNM who have
what's called an optical lattice this is
so cool you have a bunch of atoms
floating in space held in place by a
couple of crossed laser beams if you
lose power the whole thing just
evaporates and whenever you want two
atoms to talk to each other you puff
them up so that their electron clouds
overlap and then they can talk to each
other and then you unpop the then the
information stays safe in their nuclei
for like up to a second which is a
really long time a really long time for
quantum things and there were other
proposals as well these do seem to be
getting now to the point of going from
theory to engineering I mean I think
that we will see quantum computers with
fifty or a hundred bits which may not
sound like a lot but it's already much
more than we can handle with standard
computers so I hope that answers your
question
possibly too much length anyone else
I wonder what you thought of the science
paper from god--all I mean cubit and
wolf and that Pierre Perez Garcia in
2015 which addressed the same subject
you're covering tonight there's a
Scientific American
summary of it but it's a hundred and
forty-six page proof of the
impossibility of doing an algorithm to
identify the spectral gap which which
materials will have a spectral graph
which one and whether you had looked at
that I know some of the papers around
that I don't know that specific one it
sounds like maybe we should have a more
technical conversation offline but it's
true that even figuring out the basic
physical properties of a complicated
material you can have the same kind of
uncomputable ax t of the halting problem
sneaked into that and I think that's
what you're referring to
yeah so for instance you could imagine
you could imagine some kind of 2 or 3
dimensional crystal where each time I go
from one row or layer of it to the next
one it's reading the previous row
carrying out some simple computation and
then somehow producing the next row so
it's like changing the time of the
computation into space going downward
would be like time and then predicting
whether this kind of crystal can hold
together over many many rows along a
large expanse becomes asking will this
computation ever halt as it goes forward
in time and so even some basic questions
like that that they don't again they
don't sound like computational questions
at first but you can sneak them in that
way
so yeah I am Mike Nielsen was on that I
think right over anyway we can talk yeah
ok great I have a question over here
you describe how some things that your
non-obvious computations or computations
in disguise yes I look forward to
reading your book and maybe it answers
this but are there are things which are
not computations such as things that
humans do cognitively or is it perhaps
the case that everything is a
computation sorry are there some
computations like what humans do that
what I'm wondering what the scope of
your book and your definition of
computation is is everything a
computation since you seem to be saying
that some things are computations in
disguise and for example those things
that we as humans do right yeah people
debate this so for instance my friend
Michael Lachlan has studied computation
and ant colonies so you know ants are
communicating with each other they're
building trails they're communicating
with pheromones and so on and they could
conceivably be carrying out a very
complicated computation by doing that
now on the other hand maybe at the
opposite extreme when the moon goes
around the earth is it computing
anything I mean you could say well it's
figuring out where it should go but it's
not clear it's doing that it's just
going there you know so you know I I was
reluctant at first to view the cells in
our body is doing computation until I
learned more about the very complicated
signals they send to each other the fact
that they can respond to all sorts of
different situations in different ways
so that started to feel to me like okay
that's big enough it's varied enough
it's not just doing one thing like the
earth going round and round it's varied
enough so that it deserves to be called
computation now the things I was talking
about here were all grounded in if you
like the sort of standard picture of
computation bits and ands and ORS I'm
not saying that's the only way to do
computation it's just it happens to be
the way that mathematically were the
best at talking about so yeah I I at the
end of the day I like to think of the
word computation as a lens through which
we can look at things and you know I you
and I might be looking at the same
system but if I'm a hardcore physicist I
may say oh well I'm studying the energy
flows in the system that's what matters
to me but you might come in and say wait
there's also flows of information going
on in the system so I want to view the
system through the computational lens
and maybe you'll learn something about
it that I won't so I'm fairly you know
I'm happy to be free willing about how
we use the word but I also like having
ironclad results that if I could
magically solve this then I could
magically solve that so if this is hard
that had better be hard to so question
over here Chris there's a hand there hi
there I'm over here when I read your the
description of your talk and saw the the
word the hard problem I thought perhaps
you might be talking about consciousness
in the sense of David Chalmers is
description of the hard problem and I
wonder if you have any comments to make
on that whether that's a simple problem
a hard problem or an impossible problem
yeah so let me just let me just fill in
so David Chalmers is a philosopher who
studies consciousness among other things
and he likes to say that the easy
problem is figuring out how the brain
works and how all the stuffs is
happening in our neurons corresponds to
our mental and emotional states he says
that's the easy part
he says the hard part is figuring out
why am I in here you know why do I have
this inner life I mean it's one thing to
analyze a very complicated material
object and figure out that it can
predict things learn things that's
glorious but then why is there this
subjective sense that I'm in here
and he calls that the hard problem and
he points out it's not really a science
problem you know it's a philosophy
problem because you could you know
you're not gonna figure that out by
sticking me in an MRI machine and doing
more experiments it's not going to get
at that nugget of what consciousness is
I'm pretty sympathetic to charmolue to
Chalmers view and I I regard the
question of consciousness as thorny er
than some of my scientist friends regard
it because of this kind of remaining
nugget of well but why is there a
subjective life it's one thing to
explain how I can walk around and talk
but why is there someone here I mean you
don't know that there is I could just be
saying that but honestly I have no I
haven't ever come up with an original
thought on this subject I I don't know
how to make any progress on it either
scientifically or philosophically so
indeed all the problems I was saying are
hard are just math problems some of
those are really hard so we have a
question over here hi Chris thank you
for your talk um I was wondering it's
kind of related to the last question but
as we look dude learn more about the way
that brain works and we only know very
very little right now as I understand it
doing some part no small part to the
fact that we don't have instruments to
get inside and really see the
computations that are going on in the
brain as we do that more do you think
that might change the way we look at
what is hard and impossible do you
expect there might be some mysterious
new way of computing in the brain that
we haven't thought about yet that would
change our definition of hard and
impossible computation yeah I think this
is a nice question because I mean I
think the brain does a lot of things I
think computation is only part of it
somehow but when the brain does the
stuff it does it doesn't seem that it's
that much about for instance dealing
with bits and flipping them on and off
and ending two of them together we
roaring to them to get
I mean as I'm sure you know the you know
our neurons do combine signals from
other neurons and if the total signal is
above some threshold at least this is
the kind of simplified model then it
sends a signal on to the next one so
it's doing some and and or ish things
but even single neurons are very dynamic
objects I learned this partly from David
Krakauer they're you know they're
they're organisms even single neurons
they're not just little wires carrying a
single bit on or off so the way that the
brain computes the way that we've
evolved to do the computation that we
need to do to survive does seem to be
very different from the way that we've
built our computing technologies and if
we understood it better it might inspire
new approaches and I there are a couple
of computer scientists who are
collaborating with neuroscientists who
are trying to figure out what are the
basic steps of which the brain is
capable sort of if the brain is running
an algorithm what are the you know what
are the elementary pieces of that
algorithm for instance often we have a
kind of population of neurons that are
all firing away and then some other part
of the brain recruits part of that
population and gets them all
synchronized and this I hear that this
is something to do with paying attention
to things and I don't really know
because I'm not a neuroscientist and
maybe some of you are but so these basic
building blocks of neural computation
may be very different from the basic
building blocks of technological
computation so we should certainly learn
more about them I think you have time
for one more I do I mean the fire
department agreed to unbar the doors at
9:30 I think just to push further on the
answers to the last two questions how
would we know if we had created a
machine that had consciousness and what
is your work tell you about the the
heart problem of figuring that out
yeah well this is another what what
another one of Alan Turing's famous
papers was about right the imitation
game which became the title of the movie
that I have mixed feelings about so
although I love Benedict Cumberbatch but
yeah so I this isn't clear to me either
for the same reason that I didn't have a
good answer to his question I mean the
idea
Turing's claim was that you know
consciousness SH monstrousness if if a
computer can carry on a conversation
with you about math music poetry
whatever and you really can't tell the
difference between then on a human then
functionally they've got what humans
have God that was his you know that
that's that claim now again there are
lots of philosophers who are violently
opposed to that point of view there's
this classic thing by a philosopher I
don't find very convincing but I guess I
should bring it up called the Chinese
the Chinese room like I name's Cyril so
Cyril has this thought experiment saying
well if I get it right questions come in
in Chinese to a room and an apparatus
you know a very complicated big
apparatus answers them and it might even
answer them by first translating them
into English and then was there a human
involved I can't remember right so the
apparatus translates them into English
and then a human answers then translates
it back okay so then the question is
will we're in this room is the
understanding of Chinese now I think I
would be comfortable with saying it's
sort of distributed it's the the whole
system the apparatus and the human
together they do understand Chinese and
actually this is easier to believe now
that it was then because now we have
reasonably good computer translation
programs so now maybe Cyril would like
to change the terms of his thought
experiment a little bit to make it
something which is even harder to
automate but it's the same way I mean I
I don't view my none of my individual
neurons is consciousness it is conscious
but I think I am as a package so now I
do also happen to believe no offence
that I'm made of atoms and stuff okay so
I think I'm a fantastic thing made of
atoms but I do think I'm made of atoms
so I I do think that someday it is
entirely possible that we could have a
computer which which really deserves to
be called conscious I also use the word
soul when I talk about myself I mean I I
you know yeah I don't think it's
something somewhere else but I think
it's something that kind of happens with
all of what's going on in me when I'm
feeling poetic I think of it like the
beauty of a sunset sunsets are made of
it's a material object but look it's
beautiful so all of this is very far off
the deep end of what I'm actually
qualified to speak about but as long as
I'm up here and wearing a suit
I guess I'll inflict my opinion on you
so there you go well thank you all
let's do one more and then I won one
more just understand now that computers
are writing stories so briefly how did
you get into this what's your story how
did I get into this well so in you know
I had a computer in high school I
enjoyed programming at bla bla bla and
then in college I read a book which
maybe some of you were read to called
gödel Escher Bach by Douglas Hofstadter
and it was a peal of surprise winning
book and it was this tour de force where
he talks about good ol Kurt gödel the
logician I was telling you about before
and assure the artist who loved
paradoxes like the staircase that keeps
going up as you go round and round and
Bach who worked a lot of beautiful
mathematical structure into his music
and even some funny
DOCSIS where you you go into it and by
the time you get all the way back out
it's not quite the key signature you
went in with and stuff like that and so
he combined in this very exciting
humanistic way this logic and art and
music and that really got me so that got
me hooked on 1936 computer science which
was you know the Alan Turing and the
halting problem and Kurt gödel and then
you know I went to some more college and
I kind of caught up to 1970s computer
science and and by then it was the 1990s
so you know I I eventually caught up but
I I think there's you know in physics
there's a lot of discussion of how how
do the atoms of a material or a liquid
or a gas combine to make a global
behavior this is kind of the style of
science we do at the Santa Fe Institute
you have lots of simple things
interacting and you have some surprising
global hood behavior emerges from that
and that's also a computation is like
each little step of an algorithm is very
simple each little variable is just a 0
or 1 and yet they work together and
interact in a way to solve some deep
complicated problem
so I think that that interface between
reductionism and holism
or between you know the parts and the
whole excited me intellectually so yeah
thank you all right thank you very much
for coming